[Music]
there's a wonderful quote by American
children's rights activist Marian Wright
Edelman which proclaims you cannot be
what you cannot see and I would add to
that unless you are exceptional this is
the case with Robert Smith who not many
people had heard of until he made global
news last week for writing off the
student loans of the whole class of 2019
at Morehouse College in the u.s. Smith's
gift was symbolic for so many reasons
here is a man who defied all the odds to
become America's richest black person
who decided to go back to his community
and help the next generation to do the
same Morehouse College class of 2019
should become a case study of what
low-income young people can achieve when
they are not saddled with crippling
amounts of student debt social mobility
has stalled and I believe one way to
jumpstart it is for the government like
Smith to wipe off the tuition fees of
our poorest kids this will go a long way
to help level the playing field so June
I fundamentally disagree with no joke
it's an amazing story yeah and I just
want to say actually on the on the fees
thing I just want to look at some of
what could have been done with the money
the students out there riddled with this
debt and instead of paying the debt off
if the parents had the opportunity to
invest say 50 thousand pounds in the
same period that that it takes them to
pay off that debt or expire which is 30
years what they end up with is something
like two hundred and something thousand
pounds of the return on that investment
and the student debt paid off now what
that tells us is the following if you
have money you can make money yeah and
that's what this man has done for these
students what he's done is he's given
them a clean slate so they're starting
life with no debt so that any money they
earn they can put back productively into
their own families and bettering their
own lives and the feeling of relief when
that's done for you let's see in fact
one student and the
she released before can I just bring in
Robert Smith himself let's go ahead on
behalf of the eight generations of my
family who have been in this country
we're going to put a little fuel in your
bus and my family is making a grant to
eliminate their student loans
[Applause]
I mean that's here the [ __ ] the long
time to realize and its thing about not
even believing that that would have been
possible and therefore not being able to
see what was beyond that now students of
course unfortunately today are in that
situation thankfully of course they
don't have to pay it back if they can't
afford to but as I say the equivalent
that that money could be put to useful
by parents another example fifty
thousand pounds could be also the
deposit on at home yeah for the
childhoods directly now yeah so before
we move to somebody else let's see what
I'm already sure had to say who's a
Morehouse graduate class of 2019 my
brothers and I are set to go into the
real world and accomplish everything
that we're supposed to accomplish
touch everyone we're supposed to touch
reach everyone who are supposed to reach
after graduation without anything on our
shoulders without anything on our
family's shoulders it's amazing it's an
incredible thing this amazing you're
gonna have no issue with me about that
however what you do have an issue with
me with is the government writing off
student tuition for the poorest kids we
do okay I just want what I want to say
is that I suppose I'm always wondering
who's gonna pay for all of this and in
my head I'm wondering why someone honor
on a low pay or a middle grade of income
we should have to pay the phase of a
university student who's gonna do much
better than than them in life when a
plumber or an electrician needs to take
a course it's gonna better them they
have to they have to pay for that
themselves so why should kids so good to
university have everything pay for the
other thing you mentioned was the
university paying this thing off we know
that they're the Institute of Fiscal
Studies says that every two kids ever
will do that but if you take a wage you
don't start paying back until it's you
weren't 21 grand again so say you're on
a wage of 26 grand Ian you paid nine
percent on everything you earned over 21
that's that's 37 pound 50 a week it's
not crippling to get a university
god-given right just a couple of points
and then I'll bring you both in reason
why I think we have to do this for our
poorest kids it's often they are the
first person in their family to go to
university and so therefore the way that
they are able to change the trajectory
of their family's life is absolutely is
exponential and therefore we should not
make those kids be saddled with debt
that then prevents them being able to
help their families to do it for them
let me finish that's the first point and
then the second piece which i think is
really important in terms of what this
means is just look at that kid and I
gave you confidence that that's given
that child get in in terms of the
investment that's been made in addition
also we know that 60% of the jobs of the
future 60% of the jobs of the future
haven't even been created yet but what
we do know is the majority of those jobs
are going to come from the tech sector
so we need to educate our young people
to rates of which we've never needed to
educate them so therefore we need to
avoid some common sense from me where
this has gone wrong is too many children
go to university Germany and and instead
of it being something that you need to
possibly be a doctor an engineer
whatever now it's almost you go to
school you go to you go to secondary
school you go to university and that's
it's wrong that's it it should be let me
just finish it should be it should be
more selective and many children waste
their time and waste their money or
their parents money doing courses that
mean nothing that I think the universe
the whole university system needs a
really really thorough review however
before I yield I find it faintly
sickening that a group of men and women
in power now who benefited from free
university education take it upon
themselves to make in your case a really
decent striving to become a doctor then
I'll bring you in Rachel to your point
don't you think the issue isn't about
too many kids going to university
issue is they're studying subjects that
we're not going to need yeah just point
out that just because more people are
going to university it doesn't mean the
system is fairer so volume does not
equal equality literally from 2012
English tuition fees suddenly tripled
and we became it became the highest in
the world personally I think we should
scrap tuition fees but everyone well
I'll tell you who's going to pay for it
actually because if we raise corporation
tax from 19% up to 26% which is not even
which is still lower which is still
lower than the level it was in 2010 the
government I don't know why you're so
exhausted this figure when I'm telling
you that eight years ago it was it was
higher it was twenty eight percent in
2010 looking at you did you not like it
then education Scotland because it's
free do you you must know what's
happening this week you know free
education can decrease equality and let
me explain that because in Scotland it's
free no tuition fees in Scotland and yet
they have to take in massive amounts of
English students and students from the
EU because they pay and and in the last
figure that were produce 2010 Lim said
that in Scotland there was only the
governor who gave ten point four million
pounds to poorer students this country
gave a third of a billion pounds to
poorer students so we kind of all doing
all bit see some point from Canada yeah
[Laughter]
debate to a close so anyone will tell
you darling that the world of showbiz
isn't always glitz and glamour writing
scripts doing rehearsals fitting in
breakfast the all-important decisions on
hair and makeup we do a lot of graft
here even on the pledge before we start
filming but you can just call us the
star students of Sky News one person
giving us a run for our money in the
goodie two-shoe stakes is comedian Frank
Skinner the funny man found
a way of getting himself into the
channels good books when he appeared on
some rise with Sarah Jane Mia
earlier this week take a look at this
Frank Skinner is with us in the studio
this morning hello Frank hello
I've just got to start by saying and Sky
News has changed your life hasn't it
we're celebrating a plan Frank is part
of that I was just saying off-camera
that watching Sky News made me feel
guilty about the fact that I have 12
bottles of water delivered every week so
now I've stopped that delivery and I
used two bottles that I just refill out
the tap so we've probably closed down
some mineral water companies but we've
saved saved some wildlife now it really
did make me think about it so you know
Sky News saves lives and whatever Frank
Skinner they're definitely showing you
house showing us how you make your
future safer with a broadcaster so he
gets aa
straight talker of the week but I'm
actually gonna call him the straight
groveler of the way news has been
transformative anyway Rachel
congratulations on your this week of the
pledge but if you want to join in the
debate all you need to do is search us
on Facebook and Twitter and the pledge
is now also available to download as a
podcast from iTunes thanks for watching
and we'll see next week five
[Music]